en el vídeo anterior definimos todas las
variables de movimiento angular y
comentamos que éstas son más sutiles que
las variables de movimiento regular para
cosas que están rotando en círculo ya
que cada punto en esta cuerda y la
pelota de tenis que está atada a ella
están girando en círculo por lo que cada
punto en la cuerda incluyendo la pelota
tendrán el mismo desplazamiento angular
velocidad angular y aceleración angular
pero aún cuando a usar estas variables
de movimiento angular es mucho más
conveniente para estos problemas de
movimiento rotacional también es
importante saber cómo traducir las
variables de movimiento angular de
regreso a las variables de movimiento
regular vamos a hacerlo la variable más
sencilla de movimiento angular es el
desplazamiento angular ya que indica
cuánto ángulo fue recorrido por un
objeto digamos que roto esta cantidad y
representamos el desplazamiento angular
con delta theta esto es el
desplazamiento angular y en física
típicamente elegimos medir esto en
radiales y en
un momento veremos por qué y cómo
convertimos esto en una variable de
movimiento regular y cuál será esa
variable de movimiento regular y si yo
viera esto por primera vez diría bueno
esto es el desplazamiento angular yo
creo que se va a relacionar con el
desplazamiento regular pero quizás sea
un poco extraño ya que si pensamos en el
movimiento regular esta pelota comenzó
aquí y llegó acá así que fue de este
punto hasta este otro punto y ese sería
el desplazamiento regular de esta pelota
el desplazamiento lineal regular pero
esto es extraño y no vamos a ver cómo
encontrar esto primero porque tendríamos
que usar la ley del coseno y esto sería
más detallado de lo que quiero que
veamos en este vídeo y la segunda razón
es porque esto no es tan útil hay una
cantidad mucho más útil y que nos dice
que tanto se desplazó esta pelota y esa
es la longitud de arco de la pelota así
que la pelota traza una ruta en el
espacio alrededor de este círculo y le
llamamos los
de arco y resulta que esto es mucho más
útil para muchos problemas y es mucho
más sencillo de encontrar que el
desplazamiento regular esta es la
longitud de arco y se usan varias letras
para representar los he visto que usan
la l pero la mayoría de los libros de
matemáticas usan s así que aquí también
vamos a usar ese y quizá piensen que es
difícil de encontrar pero no es así de
hecho el que usemos radiales nos va a
facilitar encontrar esta cantidad para
encontrar la longitud de arco que
recorrió esta pelota de tenis solo
tenemos que conocer el radio de la ruta
circular que trazó esta pelota que en
este caso es la longitud de la cuerda
este es el radio y si tenemos el ángulo
medido en radiales simplemente lo vamos
a multiplicar por esta delta teta y es
por eso que usar radiales es tan
conveniente tomamos esta medida en
radiales la multiplicamos por el radio y
obtenemos la longitud de arco que es
la ruta circular que ha trazado el
objeto la longitud de arco es el número
de metros que ha recorrido esta pelota
en esta ruta circular y si resulta
asombroso realmente no lo es
esto fue diseñado justamente por cómo se
define un radial un radial se define
como el ángulo en el que viajamos de
manera que la longitud de arco sea igual
al radio de este círculo así que no nos
sorprende porque esto fue diseñado
estratégicamente de manera que podamos
usar esta unidad y convertir muy
fácilmente el desplazamiento angular que
es cuántos radiales ha recorrido el
objeto al rotar y cuántos metros ha
viajado realmente a través de su arco
por lo que la longitud del arco va a
tener unidades de metros siempre y
cuando miramos el radio en metros y esta
es la relación entre el desplazamiento
angular o cuánto ángulo ha recorrido un
objeto que está rotando y cuántos metros
ha recorrido
la siguiente relación que veremos tiene
que ver con la velocidad angular y la
velocidad regular recuerden que en el
vídeo anterior definimos la velocidad
angular como el desplazamiento angular
por tiempo es la tasa a la que está
rotando algo en cierta cantidad de
ángulo y la letra que usamos para
representar la velocidad angular es la
letra griega o mega la velocidad angular
representa la tasa a lo que algo está
rotando en un círculo si rota lentamente
pues tendrá una menor velocidad angular
y si rota rápidamente tendrá una mayor
velocidad angular así que la rapidez y
la velocidad angular van a estar
relacionados ya que mientras mayor sea
la velocidad angular mayor será la
rapidez pero cuál es esta relación como
pasamos de la velocidad angular a la
rapidez regular pues no es tan difícil
todo lo que tenemos que hacer es tomar
esta cantidad que está en radiales por
segundo y transformarlo a metros por
segundo y podemos hacer esto
multiplicando a ambos lados de esta
ecuación por r
r por omega igual a ere por delta teta y
lo divido entre delta t simplemente
multiplicamos ambos lados de esta
ecuación por r pero vean que lo que
obtuve es r por delta theta que es la
longitud de arco así que este lado me
dice cuántos metros ha viajado el objeto
alrededor del borde de este círculo
dividido entre el tiempo que le llevó a
hacer esto y justamente esto es la
rapidez la longitud de arco es la
distancia que el objeto ha viajado y el
tiempo es el tiempo que le llevó a hacer
este recorrido y la distancia por tiempo
es la rapidez así que esto es la rapidez
del objeto lo escribo como v aún cuando
esto no es la velocidad esto no es un
vector y por lo tanto no es la velocidad
ya que vean que esta longitud de arco no
es un desplazamiento es la distancia
recorrida por el objeto la distancia por
tiempo es la rapidez y el desplazamiento
por tiempo es la velocidad a quien no
usamos desplazamiento l
es esta cosa rara que no calculamos y ya
que estamos usando la longitud de arco
que es distancia pues vamos a relacionar
la velocidad angular con la rapidez y ya
tenemos esta relación está r es el radio
multiplicado por la velocidad angular y
esto es igual a la rapidez del objeto
por lo que esta es la relación entre la
velocidad angular y la rapidez la
rapidez del objeto es igual al radio de
la ruta circular seguida por el objeto
multiplicada por la velocidad angular
del mismo vamos a resaltar estas
fórmulas esta fórmula de la longitud de
arco nos dice cómo relacionar los
radiales que ha recorrido un objeto al
rotar y cuánta longitud de arco ha
viajado en esta rotación es decir la
distancia recorrida y la fórmula de aquí
abajo me relacionan la velocidad angular
o mega el número de radiales por segundo
que algo recorre en su ruta circular lo
relaciona con cuántos metros por segundo
ha recorrido este objeto
en otras palabras cuántos metros
atrasado junto con esta longitud de arco
y ahora tenemos la relación entre la
longitud de arco y la distancia que ha
recorrido algo y esto es bueno ahora
podemos relacionar el desplazamiento
angular con la distancia recorrida por
el objeto y sabemos cómo relacionar la
velocidad angular con la rapidez del
objeto y seguramente ya se imaginan qué
es lo que viene ahorita vamos a
relacionar la aceleración angular con la
aceleración regular recordemos que la
aceleración angular que representamos
con la letra griega alfa se define como
el cambio en la velocidad angular entre
el tiempo es la tasa a la cual la
velocidad angular está cambiando por lo
que si nos movemos a una tasa constante
no vamos a tener una aceleración angular
ya que no tendremos ningún cambio en
omega pero si omega comienza despacio y
va aumentando cada vez más tendremos una
aceleración angular y probablemente no
le sorprenda que si tenemos aceleración
angular esta pelota también
la aceleración regular ya que está
aumentando su rapidez en su movimiento
angular por lo que estará cambiando su
velocidad también y como relacionamos la
aceleración angular con la aceleración
regular pues veamos que hicimos aquí
simplemente multiplicamos ambos lados de
la ecuación por el radio y encontramos
la relación entre la rapidez y la
velocidad angular vamos a intentarlo de
nuevo vamos a multiplicar ambos lados de
esta ecuación por r del lado derecho me
queda el radio por la aceleración
angular y del lado izquierdo me queda el
radio multiplicado por el cambio en la
velocidad angular entre el tiempo lo
único que hicimos es multiplicar ambos
lados de esta ecuación por el radio y
que nos queda del lado derecho
tenemos r por delta omega y esto es r
por el cambio en omega que es omega
final menos omega inicial- y lo
dividimos entre delta te distribuyó esta
r de manera que esto me quede igual
report o mega final - ere por omega
inicial / del tate pero ahora tenemos
ere por omega final menos ere por omega
inicial- y conocemos que es ere por
omega es la rapidez no la velocidad sino
la rapidez por lo que puedo reescribir
esto de manera que me quedan
la rapidez final menos la rapidez
inicial entre el cambio en el tiempo y
esto es a lo que es igual ere por alfa y
quizás se vean tentados a decir a miren
pues esta es la aceleración el cambio de
la rapidez entre el tiempo pero hay que
tener cuidado
la verdadera aceleración es un vector y
es el cambio en la velocidad entre el
tiempo pero estos no son vectores de
velocidad
esto es rapidez por lo que este no es el
verdadero vector aceleración esto es
algo diferente es el cambio en la
rapidez entre el tiempo sigue siendo una
aceleración pero no necesariamente es
toda la aceleración ya que tenemos dos
formas de acelerar podremos cambiar la
rapidez o podremos cambiar la dirección
y esta aceleración que acabamos de
encontrar básicamente no toma para nada
en cuenta la aceleración que viene del
cambio de dirección es solo la
aceleración que viene del cambio en la
rapidez y si yo fuera ustedes
probablemente estaría confundida en este
punto voy a tratar de explicarles qué
significa esto si esta pelota está
rotando en un círculo por el simple
hecho de que esta pelota está rotando en
un círculo significa que está acelerando
aún cuando la pelota no aumenta o
disminuye su rapidez aquí tenemos una
aceleración ya que esta pelota está
cambiando la dirección de su velocidad
es decir tiene que haber una fuerza
centrípeta que en este caso es la
tensión y tiene que haber una
aceleración centrípeta para poder
cambiar la dirección de la velocidad y
ésta
no es la aceleración de aquí ésta es una
aceleración diferente sabemos que la
aceleración centrípeta se dirige hacia
adentro y ya sabemos cómo encontrar la
aceleración centrípeta en esta fórmula
es la rapidez al cuadrado dividida entre
el radio este componente esta
aceleración centrípeta es el componente
de la aceleración que cambia la
dirección de la velocidad voy a decirlo
otra vez porque es importante la
aceleración centrípeta que podemos
encontrar con b al cuadrado entre r es
el componente de la aceleración que
cambia la dirección de la velocidad y si
algo va en círculo debe tener
aceleración centrípeta pero este
componente de la aceleración que
encontramos aquí es diferente aquí
tenemos lo que está cambiando la rapidez
y no tenemos que tener esto si estamos
moviéndonos en un círculo podemos
imaginar a algo que viaja en un círculo
a una tasa constante y si esto sucede
tendremos a aceleración centrípeta pero
no tendrá esta cosa de aquí abajo esto
que encontramos r por alfa es el cambio
en la rapidez del objeto por el tiempo
como puedo dibujar esto para
representarlo en esta gráfica la dibujo
tangencial a la dirección del movimiento
es decir tangente al círculo ya que los
componentes de la aceleración que
estaban dirigidos perpendicularmente a
la velocidad cambian la dirección de la
velocidad pero los componentes de la
aceleración que son paralelos a la
dirección de la velocidad cambian la
magnitud de la velocidad es decir la
rapidez cambian la magnitud de la
velocidad lo que es decir para aumentar
o disminuir la rapidez de algo
necesitamos un componente de esa
aceleración que esté ya sea en la
dirección del movimiento u opuesta a la
dirección del movimiento si está opuesta
a la dirección del movimiento la
aceleración va a estar haciendo que el
objeto vaya más despacio y si el
componente de la aceleración
en la misma dirección que el movimiento
entonces va a hacer que este objeto vaya
más rápido y esto es lo que encontramos
aquí este componente de la aceleración r
por alfa que muchas veces se le llama
componente tangencial de la aceleración
vamos a escribirlo por acá la
aceleración tangencial que es igual a r
por alfa el radio por la aceleración
angular es el componente de la
aceleración que cambia la magnitud de la
velocidad es decir cambia la rapidez y
para hacer esto su dirección tiene que
ser tangencial a la dirección del
movimiento y es lo que representa esta r
por alfa esta es la fórmula para
encontrar la aceleración tangencial no
nos da la aceleración total pues sabemos
que siempre va a haber un componente de
la aceleración que va a estar actuando
de forma centrípeta si es que un objeto
se está moviendo en círculo y está le
encontramos con v al cuadrado entre r
pero si el objeto que se mueve en
círculo
ademá
está aumentando su rapidez no solo se
mueve en círculos sino que también
aumenta su rapidez también va a tener
este componente de la aceleración que es
la aceleración tangencial y quizá esto
los confunda un poco ya que tenemos
aceleración tangencial y aceleración
centrípeta cuál de éstas es la
aceleración bueno ambas son componentes
de la aceleración total que pueden
encontrar si realmente quieren
encontrarla como aceleración total al
cuadrado es igual y aquí usamos el
teorema de pitágoras ya que estos son
los componentes perpendiculares de la
aceleración total por lo que la
aceleración total al cuadrado va a ser
igual a la aceleración tangencial al
cuadrado más la aceleración centrípeta
al cuadrado y así tendremos la
aceleración total al cuadrado y si
queremos encontrar la dirección de esta
aceleración total va a apuntar hacia
abajo si tenemos la aceleración
centrípeta hacia adentro y él
está aumentando su rapidez no está yendo
más despacio está yendo más rápido
tenemos este componente y ese componente
que va hacia adentro la aceleración
total tendrá una dirección más o menos
hacia acá y ya que podemos formar un
triángulo con esto podemos imaginar que
movemos la aceleración centrípeta a este
otro extremo y podemos encontrar la
hipotenusa que será la aceleración total
y lo hacemos tomando la aceleración
tangencial al cuadrado más la
aceleración centrípeta al cuadrado y el
resultado le sacamos la raíz cuadrada y
así obtendremos la aceleración total en
resumen tenemos dos componentes de la
aceleración la aceleración tangencial
que es r por alfa ya sea que aumenta su
rapidez o lo hace más lento la
aceleración centrípeta sirve para
cambiar el movimiento del objeto y la
podemos relacionar la rapidez de un
objeto con la velocidad angular del
mismo al multiplicar la por el radio y
podemos relacionar la longitud de arco
que es la distancia que viaja el objeto
al
de el círculo con el desplazamiento
angular multiplicando la también por el
radio con estas tres ecuaciones es como
relacionamos las variables del
movimiento angular con las variables de
movimiento regular